MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Es ist alles ... deprimierend.
Die Schweizer Botschaft
schrieb zurück,
wir seien quasi selber schuld
und auf uns alleine gestellt.
Mit jedem Tag wird der Wunsch
grösser, endlich zu Hause zu sein.
Deshalb wird es immer belastender.
Ich befinde mich zwar
vor einer schönen Kulisse,
aber es kommt
keine Ferienstimmung auf.
Der ständige Druck,
nach Hause zu wollen
und nicht zu wissen, wie es
weitergeht, macht einen kaputt.
Es ist die Eigenverantwortung
jedes Mitbürgers, dafür zu sorgen,
so schnell wie möglich
zurück in die Schweiz zu kommen.
Der Bundesrat ruft jene auf,
die zurück in die Schweiz wollen,
jetzt zurückzukommen
und nicht weitere Tage zu warten.
Der Flugverkehr ist
wegen der Corona-Krise kollabiert.
Tausende Schweizer
sind im Ausland gestrandet
und wollen
möglichst schnell nach Hause.
Die Frage ist nur: Wie?
Willst du schon aufnehmen?
- Ja.
Wie man hier sieht,
ist der Strand ziemlich leer,
weil es geregnet hat
und schon Abend ist.
Nur die Wenigsten tragen Masken.
Den Menschen geht es gut,
jeder lacht.
Man spricht nicht gross
über das Virus.
Allen ist bewusst,
dass es das Virus gibt.
Aber die Menschen
gehen sich nicht aus dem Weg.
Und die Einheimischen,
die eine Maske tragen -
wir haben nachgefragt -,
tragen diese nur
während des Motorradfahrens
aufgrund der staubigen Luft.
Ja, genau. Es ist hier um einiges
ruhiger als bei euch in der Schweiz.
Das Coronavirus
ist zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahmen
noch kein Thema auf Bali.
Aber die Pandemie
ist weltweit auf dem Vormarsch,
immer mehr Flugverbindungen
werden eingestellt.
Grundsätzlich haben wir keine Angst.
Es ist eine Unsicherheit,
ob und wann wir zurückkönnen.
Es geht aber nicht allen so.
Zwei Mitreisende von uns
nehmen es etwas lockerer als wir.
Wir haben entschieden,
dass wir zurückwollen.
Wir hoffen, dass wir
den morgigen Flieger nehmen können.
(Frau) Ich bin auf meinem
täglichen Rundgang, Spaziergang,
um die frische Luft zu geniessen.
Denn wenn man nach draussen kann,
muss man es auch ausnützen.
Das ist der Weg.
Hier hat man die Möglichkeit,
rund um das ganze Schiff zu gehen.
Hier sieht man nach unten
auf die eine Seite.
Karin Hartmann
ist mit ihren Eltern und einer Tante
auf einer Südamerika-Kreuzfahrt,
die zwei Wochen dauern sollte.
Das ist unser Reich.
Das Zimmer
ist für zwei Personen konzipiert.
Hier sieht man das Bett.
Etwas weiter vorne ist unser Balkon.
Es ist sehr angenehm.
Momentan ist es eher etwas tropisch.
Aber man hat
eine sehr schöne Aussicht aufs Meer.
Heute Morgen sind ein paar Delfine
vorbeigeschwommen.
Man hat während den Tagen auf See
in etwa immer die gleiche Aussicht.
Eigentlich sollte ich
seit letztem Dienstag
wieder zurück in der Schweiz sein.
Aber daraus wurde nichts.
Die Reise hätte vom 1. bis 15. März
stattfinden sollen.
Am 15. März sind wir auch wie
geplant in San Antonio angekommen.
Wir konnten allerdings
nicht an Land gehen.
Um Mitternacht wurden alle Häfen
in Amerika geschlossen,
in Nord- und Südamerika.
Morgens um 2.30 Uhr
sind wir am Hafen angekommen,
durften aber
nicht mehr an Land gehen.
Das ist unser Airbnb.
Die Bali-Urlauber haben angefangen,
ihre Koffer zu packen.
Denn sie haben gehört,
dass der Bundesrat
alle Schweizer aufgefordert hat,
nach Hause zu kommen.
Also haben sie versucht,
so schnell wie möglich einen Flug
in die Schweiz zu bekommen.
Doch sie haben schnell gemerkt: Das
ist im Moment gar nicht so einfach.
Wir haben eigentlich
alle möglichen Stellen kontaktiert:
die Schweizer Botschaft
in Indonesien ...
Wir informierten uns auch täglich
auf der Webseite des BAG,
bei Singapore Airlines, beim EDA.
Wir bekamen nirgends eine richtige
Antwort, nur automatische Antworten.
Oft ging niemand ans Telefon.
Die Schweizer Botschaft
schrieb zurück,
wir seien quasi selber schuld
und auf uns alleine gestellt,
wir müssten die Situation
selbst bewältigen.
Das hat uns doch sehr verunsichert.
* Husten, Miauen *
Hinten ist eine Katze.
Ja, die Katze kommt auch mit,
sie ist auch gestrandet.
Ja, so ist es. Wir sind
mit Sack und Pack unterwegs.
Das ist Conny.
Ich bin hier, weil ich
eine Sendung über sie machte,
die ironischerweise
"SRF bi de Lüt - Heimweh" heisst.
Conny hat gestern
ihr altes Haus verlassen.
Sie haben es verkauft
und mussten raus.
Und so wie es aussieht,
sind vielleicht
wir alle drei gestrandet.
Die Katze und du auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe aktuell
noch einen Flug am Sonntag.
Aber wer weiss schon,
ob der noch stattfindet,
denn momentan gibt es weltweit
nur noch wenige Flüge.
Seine Protagonistin nimmt den
SRF-Reporter noch ein Stück weit mit,
dann muss er versuchen,
alleine weiterzukommen.
Das ist einer der grössten
Supermärkte Neuseelands.
Wie Migros oder Coop.
Eine der beliebtesten Produktgruppen
ist momentan ja WC-Papier.
Und hier ...
... herrschen
paradiesische Zustände.
Alles voll.
Kaufen Sie WC-Papier?
- Nein.
Ein Weinhändler sagte mir mal,
sein Business sei unzerstörbar,
denn in guten Zeiten trinken
die Leute viel Wein bzw. Alkohol
und in schlechten Zeiten
noch viel mehr.
Ich glaube, er hat recht.
Hier wäre sonst Bier.
In 2 Std. trennen sich unsere Wege.
Ich habe ein Auto gemietet.
Ich wollte heute
telefonisch nachfragen,
ob die Reservation noch besteht.
Aber es kam stets die Meldung,
die Leitungen seien überlastet.
(Radio) Now he announced
that there are 43 new cases,
bringing the total in New Zealand
to 155.
Ich starte hier meist
mit einem kleinen Work-out.
Wenn man so lange auf See ist,
muss man sich
ein Programm zusammenstellen.
15 Tage
hätte die Kreuzfahrt dauern sollen,
jetzt ist Tag 26
und kein Ende in Sicht.
(Mann)
Kein Mensch ist am Strand.
Das Betreten des Strandes
ist auch nicht erlaubt.
Ich stehe hier innerhalb
der Abzäunung des Hotelgartens.
Das ist mein Zuhause
für die nächsten paar Tage.
Wir werden noch sehen, wie lange.
Ich darf das Hotelareal
momentan nicht verlassen,
weil eine Ausgangssperre herrscht.
Die meisten Touristen sind abgereist,
einer harrt unfreiwillig aus.
Bezüglich meines Rückflugs habe ich
noch keine Informationen erhalten.
Ich habe beschlossen, abzuwarten
und zu schauen, was passiert.
Mehr kann man auch nicht tun.
Es bringt auch nichts,
wenn man sich aufregt.
Ich war noch nie so nervös,
bevor ich
einen Mietwagen abgeholt habe.
Hoffen wir das Beste.
Ich bin der Einzige,
der hier etwas will.
Ich hoffe mal ...
* Er stöhnt. *
Ich hatte Glück.
Ich bekam ein Mietauto.
Sie sagte,
ich hätte wirklich Glück gehabt,
denn morgen werden sie
womöglich auch schliessen.
Und zurückgeben könne ich ihn immer.
Damit wäre dieses Problem gelöst.
Hier geht es allerdings
nicht nach draussen.
Ich fahre nun zu meiner Schwester,
die in Neuseeland lebt.
Das ist 6 Std. entfernt von hier.
Mir steht
eine längere Autofahrt bevor.
Und hier bin ich
wohl schon wieder falsch.
Am Sonntagabend hat
der peruanische Präsident verkündet,
dass die Grenzen und alle Flughäfen
innerhalb von 24 Std.
geschlossen werden.
Als wir spätabends von Machu Picchu
ins Hostel zurückgekehrt sind
und davon erfahren haben,
haben wir und unsere Eltern
sofort versucht,
online Flugtickets zu buchen,
erst einmal von Cusco nach Lima,
denn wir sind momentan noch in Cusco
und nicht in der Hauptstadt.
Das hat online
nicht mehr funktioniert.
Alle Flüge
waren in kürzester Zeit ausgebucht.
Am Montag um 3 Uhr morgens sind wir
zum Flughafen in Cusco gefahren,
als dieser gerade öffnete.
Wir waren dann 6-7 Std. am Flughafen
und versuchten,
bei verschiedensten Airlines
noch ein Ticket zu ergattern.
Businessclass, egal was,
wir wollten einfach nach Hause.
Aber es klappte nicht,
wir wurden überall zurückgewiesen.
Die Flüge waren völlig überbucht,
man konnte uns nicht weiterhelfen.
Dann entschieden wir uns,
zurück ins Hostel zu gehen.
Das ist unser Restaurant,
in dem wir jeden Morgen
unser Frühstück bekommen.
Wir können auch hier
zu Mittag und zu Abend essen.
Das kostet aber zusätzlich.
In Peru
herrscht seither Ausgangssperre.
Die Touristen sind in ihrem Hostel
gefangen - auf unbestimmte Zeit.
Gehen wir mal rein.
Wir teilen uns dieses Zimmer
mit sieben anderen Personen.
Bzw., da wir zu zweit sind,
mit sechs anderen Personen.
Das ist mein Bett.
Wir haben uns
einen Nahrungsvorrat angelegt.
Gesundheitlich sind wir alle fit.
Die Ungewissheit
nagt aber natürlich an der Psyche.
Wir wissen nicht,
wann wir hier rauskommen,
wie lange das alles dauert.
Wir sind froh, dass sich
die Schweizer Botschaft bemüht,
dass wir möglichst bald
nach Hause kommen.
Das beruhigt natürlich.
Es gibt aber eine Ungewissheit
wegen der peruanischen Regierung,
die nicht kooperativ
zu sein scheint.
Wir wissen deshalb noch nicht,
wann wir es nach Hause schaffen.
Das kostet auch viel Energie.
Die Tage sind hier,
wie schon gesagt, sehr lange und ...
Der ständige Druck,
nach Hause zu wollen
und nicht zu wissen, wie es
weitergeht, macht einen kaputt.
Gestern sagte ich noch,
ich möchte cool bleiben
und einfach abwarten, was passiert.
Das ist mir nicht ganz gelungen.
Denn im Laufe des Vormittags
hat mich mein Fahrer angerufen.
Er sagte,
die Polizei sei zu ihm gekommen
und habe ihn zu Hause
unter Selbstquarantäne gesetzt.
Mit einem Schild vor dem Haus,
das signalisiert,
dass er unter Quarantäne sei.
Ich habe dann noch die Homepage
von Edelweiss besucht und gesehen,
dass plötzlich
nur noch ein Flug im Flugplan ist,
nämlich jener vom 27.
Ich habe dann sofort meine
Kontaktlady in Colombo angerufen.
Das tat ich bereits am Samstag
mit der Bitte,
sie solle mir
einen früheren Flug buchen.
Ich hatte seither
nichts mehr von ihr gehört.
Sie sagte, sie rufe mich zurück.
Es vergingen dann
1 Std., 2 Std., 3 Std. ...
Ich rief sie dann wieder an
und sie sagte,
sie habe einen Sitz
für mich freigehalten,
aber die Umbuchung
müsse in Zürich vonstattengehen.
So.
Ich bin ganz alleine im Hotel.
Es gibt Abendessen.
Es gibt nicht mehr alles,
was auf der Karte ist.
Wegen der Ausgangssperre können sie
nicht mehr alles besorgen.
Ich habe es geschafft.
Kurz vor Mitternacht bin ich
in Mount Maunganui angekommen.
Hier wohnt meine Schwester.
Kein Licht mehr,
es schlaffen wohl alle.
Die Neuseeländer
gehen allgemein früh zu Bett,
20 Uhr ist für sie
wie für uns Mitternacht.
Darum sehe ich sie
dann wahrscheinlich morgen.
Ich bin froh, hier zu sein.
Noch glücklicher ist meine Mutter.
Sie hat mir geschrieben und quasi
befohlen, sofort hierherzufahren,
die Lage sei ernst
und sie mache sich Sorgen.
Darum: Mami, ich bin hier.
Du kannst beruhigt sein.
Ich bin hier mit meinem Sohn Amaru,
der sechs Jahre alt ist.
Wir sitzen in Spanien fest -
unter Quarantäne.
(Handy) N.
- N.
Amaru und seine Mutter
sind gerade nach Spanien gezogen.
Als die Corona-Krise kam,
überlegten sie,
das Land zu verlassen.
* Monotone, bedrückende Klänge *
Inzwischen herrscht Ausgangssperre.
Und Spanien ist zurzeit das am
schwersten betroffene Land in Europa.
Ich liebe dich.
Oh, ich dich auch! Ganz fest!
Wir haben keine Angst.
Wir haben keine Angst,
in Spanien zu sein und ...
Also um uns habe ich keine Angst.
Und Amaru hat auch keine Angst.
Aber wir haben
natürlich schon vor ...
Einen kurzen Moment lang
hat er sich etwas gefürchtet.
Eben: Coronavirus, Tote usw.
Er fragte mich,
ob er daran sterben könnte -
das war vor ein paar Tagen,
als es losging.
Ich sagte ihm,
Kinder könnten nicht daran sterben,
er müsse sich keine Gedanken machen.
Seither läuft es gut.
Tag 28, zwei Tage vor der
geplanten Ankunft in San Diego,
bekamen wir Bescheid,
dass wir Flüge in die Schweiz haben.
Wir werden in San Diego
einen Bus nach Los Angeles nehmen.
Von dort werden wir via London
nach Zürich gelangen.
Wir sind gespannt,
wie das Ganze ablaufen wird.
Ich freue mich natürlich darauf.
Es ist aber auch
ein etwas seltsames Gefühl,
denn man verlässt mehr oder weniger
den sicheren Hafen
und wird in eine etwas
ungewisse Situation geschickt -
man hört ja,
was in der Schweiz abläuft.
Aber ich freue mich
natürlich sehr auf die Heimat.
Und auf die eignen vier Wände.
Bei Singapore Airlines
konnte man die Flüge,
obwohl sie storniert worden waren,
online immer noch buchen.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach
unverständlich.
Jetzt haben wir einen Flug gefunden,
bei Qatar Airways.
Jetzt sieht der Plan so aus,
dass wir von hier
nach Jakarta fliegen,
von dort nach Doha
und von Doha nach Zürich.
Hoi-hoi!
Bist du bereit?
- Um nach Hause zu gehen?
Jawohl.
- Endlich, ja.
Die Koffer sind gepackt -
let's go!
Wir sind im Taxi zum Flughafen.
Wie fühlst du dich?
Äh ... Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin froh, nach Hause zu gehen.
Und ich hoffe,
dass wir nach Hause können.
Es ist alles ... deprimierend.
Und ... es hat ...
Ich befinde mich zwar
vor einer schönen Kulisse,
aber es kommt
keine Ferienstimmung auf.
Hier ist es etwas unheimlich.
Das ganze Hotel wird eingemottet.
Es soll vorerst
für drei Monate geschlossen werden.
Es ist ein seltsames Gefühl.
Eigentlich warten alle
nur noch darauf, dass ich abreise.
Mit der Zeit
verlieren wir alle auch an Energie.
Jeder Tag wird etwas anstrengender.
Mit jedem Tag
wird der Wunsch grösser,
endlich zu Hause zu sein.
Deshalb wird es immer belastender.
Wir hoffen jetzt natürlich sehr,
dass unser Rückflug
bald stattfinden wird.
Für die meisten in unserem Hostel
ist es momentan am wichtigsten,
möglichst bald zuverlässige
Informationen zu erhalten,
mit genauen Informationen
zu den Flügen.
Da zählen wir jetzt
natürlich wirklich
auf das diplomatische Können
der Schweizer.
Flugzeuge hätte es genug.
Auch die Schweiz
fängt nun an, sie zu chartern,
um ihre Bürger nach Hause zu holen.
Gute Nachrichten
für die Tausenden von Schweizer
Touristinnen und Touristen
die wegen der Corona-Krise
im Ausland festsitzen:
Sie können
auf eine baldige Heimreise hoffen.
Für diese Menschen
organisiert die Schweiz,
alleine oder zusammen
mit anderen Ländern, Sonderflüge
oder unterstützt kommerzielle Flüge.
Die ersten Repatriierungsflüge
sind inzwischen in Zürich gelandet,
weitere sollen folgen.
* Kichern *
Good morning.
Wie geht's?
Der SRF-Reporter
ist bei seinem Schwager
und seiner Schwester angekommen.
Habe ich ein gutes Geschenk
mitgebracht?
Nein, nicht einmal verfrüht.
Eigentlich
hätte ich am Sonntag einen Flug.
Dessen Status ist bestätigt.
Jetzt kommt hier aber der Hinweis
Rescheduled ...
... ohne weitere Infos.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
kein gutes Zeichen.
Hm.
Soll er jetzt für immer hierbleiben?
Damit er immer mit dir spielen kann?
Dann können wir
den ganzen Tag spielen.
Wer weiss schon,
wie lange ich hierbleibe.
Ich wäre überhaupt nicht erstaunt,
wenn dein Flug
abgesagt werden würde.
Ich bin eher erstaunt,
dass sie noch fliegen.
* Das Mädchen
sagt etwas Unverständliches. *
Dazu braucht es ein Loch.
Vielleicht
sehe ich dich noch laufen.
Dafür müsstest du noch eine Weile
hierbleiben. Schau, die Blasen!
Endlich wieder Sonne.
Endlich wieder einmal
wirklich gutes Wetter.
Und dort hinten -
ich weiss nicht, ob man es sieht -
ist das Meer.
Manchmal sieht man
ein Frachtschiff vorbeifahren.
Der Blick in die Ferne
hilft einem sehr in der Quarantäne.
Dass ich
eine solche Aussicht habe ...
... und in die Ferne blicken kann.
Wir schleichen ein wenig
im Quartier herum. Ehrlich gesagt.
Gell, Amaru?
Schickst du das an die Polizei?
- Nein.
* Amaru spricht undeutlich. *
Hm?
Du musst warten, Amaru.
Wir müssen noch kurz warten.
Man darf ja nicht
einfach so flanieren gehen.
Das tun wir auch nicht.
Wir waren einkaufen.
Aber wir gehen dann eben ...
Normalerweise
gehen wir nicht so langsam.
Wir tun dies nur, weil wir ...
Wir wollen ein wenig draussen sein
und die frische Luft geniessen.
* Sie singt: "Isn't She Lovely"
von Stevie Wonder. *
Camilla Landboe hat angefangen,
von ihrem Balkon aus
Konzerte fürs Quartier zu geben.
* Vereinzelter Beifall *
Muchas gracias.
Hasta la proxima.
Es ist 6 Uhr morgens.
Mein Fahrer
hat mich pünktlich abgeholt.
Meine Sorge, dass sich
kein Fahrer auftreiben lässt,
hat sich zum Glück nicht bestätigt.
Die 2-m-Regel wird hier
nur sehr bedingt umgesetzt.
Nun hat es geklappt.
Ich habe meine Boardingkarte.
Jetzt sollte eigentlich
nichts mehr passieren.
Okay, dort unten ist man
tatsächlich beim Boarding.
So, jetzt sind wir im Flieger.
Bis später würde ich sagen.
Die einen konnten ihre Rückreise
selber organisieren.
Den anderen
half die Fluggesellschaft.
Oder der Reiseveranstalter.
Oder das EDA.
Oder schlicht das Glück.
Tatsache ist aber auch:
Mehr als 10'000 Schweizer
sitzen weiter im Ausland fest.
Wir sind endlich
in der Schweiz angekommen.
Nach einer Reise von 27 Std.
Nach einer ziemlichen Prozedur
sind wir endlich in Zürich gelandet.
Es ist
ein wirklich megacooles Gefühl.
Wir sind jetzt wieder in der Heimat.
Es hat alles gut geklappt -
mit einem wunderschönen Abschluss,
mit dem Flug von London nach Zürich.
Wir sind froh,
dass alles geklappt hat.
Mal schauen,
was uns in der Schweiz erwartet.
So, jetzt bin ich zu Hause
und ich werde mich
zu Hause etwas erholen.
So, zurück in der Schweiz.
Eine spezielle Ankunft.
So alleine.
Man spürt schon: Auch hier wird es
in nächster Zeit nicht lustig.